esta vez nos piden que encontremos la
suma de este par de fracciones
simplificamos la respuesta y le
escribamos como un número mixto ahora
date cuenta que aquí tenemos 4 sobre 9 4
novenos + 11 entre 12 11 12 años y el
problema el grave problema de este
asunto es que no tenemos el mismo
denominador si tuviéramos el mismo
denominador sería muy fácil encontrar la
suma lo único que tendríamos que hacer
es sumar las cantidades de arriba sin
embargo el problema es que no tenemos el
mismo denominador así que para esto
necesitamos escribir tanto 4 sobre 9
como 11 sobre 12 como fracciones que
tengan un denominador común para que así
las podamos sumar y bueno para encontrar
el denominador común que estamos
buscando hay varias formas de hacerlo
una de ellas es buscar el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 9 y 12 o tal vez se me
ocurre que una mucho más sencilla sea
fijarme en los múltiplos de 9 me voy a
fijar en los
de 9 y voy a ver cuál de ellos es el
primero que es divisible entre 2 así que
vamos a ponerlos por aquí a ver los
múltiplos de 9 bueno empezamos con 9
pero 9 no es divisible entre 12 por lo
tanto vamos a ver el siguiente 18 18
tampoco es divisible entre 12 27 7 por
13 27 pero 27 ni siquiera es un número
par después sigue 36 36 o de lujo un 36
si es divisible entre 12 12 por tres es
36 por lo tanto ya encontramos nuestro
famoso y nuestro muy útil denominador
común es 36 porque es el primero de los
factores de 9 que es divisible entre 12
ok entonces ahora vamos a escribir todo
en el denominador común 4 novenos lo voy
a ver con un denominador de 36 y 11
entre 12 también lo voy a ver con el
denominador de 36 y para esto fíjate
bien lo que vamos a hacer lo primero que
voy a fijarme es en esta fracción que
tengo aquí cuatro novenos ahora 49 no es
una fracción que va
para escribirse con un denominador de 36
fíjate que el 9 lo que hicimos fue
multiplicarlo por 4 para llegar al 36 al
9 lo multiplicamos por cuatro para
llegar al 36 ahora sí 9 los
multiplicamos por cuatro para llegar al
36 y queremos que esta fracción se
mantenga igual por lo tanto en la parte
de arriba hay que hacerle exactamente lo
mismo para convertir a esta fracción con
un denominador de 36 entonces voy a
multiplicar por 4 para que la fracción
se mantenga exactamente igual y ya tenga
mi denominador común 4 x 4 es 16 así que
la parte de arriba me queda 16 y la
parte de abajo me queda 36 el numerador
16 el denominador 36 ok ahora me voy a
tomar la suma de y me voy a fijar en la
fracción 11 entre 12 y la voy a
transformar en una fracción que tenga
como denominador a 36 entonces vamos a
fijarnos ahora en nuestra fracción de
aquí y para esto date cuenta que es lo
que estoy haciendo es multiplicar al 12
multiplicar 12 por 3 para llegar al 36
y de igual manera entonces voy a
multiplicar la parte de arriba por 3
para que no se altere esta fracción y
tengamos ahora el denominador que
queremos 11 por 3 es 33 33 y estoy
haciendo lo mismo tanto arriba como
abajo y entonces puedo decir que 33
entre 36 es exactamente lo mismo que 11
entre 2
estoy multiplicando tanto arriba como
abajo por 3 y ahora realmente lo que me
quiero tomar es la suma de estos dos y
bueno para tomarme la suma de estos dos
puedo decir que ya tenemos un
denominador común que es 36 y entonces
la respuesta me va a quedar dividida
entre 36 ok y lo que hay que hacer es
tomarme la suma de 16 de 16 porque ya
tenemos el denominador común ya esto le
voy a sumar 33 16 más 33 de color
naranja ok y bueno 16 más 33 es
exactamente lo mismo
63 19 49 esto es lo mismo que 49 entre
36 entre 36 y ya está aquí tenemos la
primera parte de este problema
encontramos la suma de estas dos
fracciones ahora me pide que
simplifiquemos la respuesta pero quiero
que te des cuenta que 49 lo único que
tiene es 49 avan séptima y bueno se
puede dividir también entre la unidad es
decir que 49 es exactamente lo mismo que
siente por 7 y 36 no tiene como factor
al 77 por nada me da 36 de una manera
exacta por lo tanto puedo decir que 49
entre 36 es una fracción irreducible ya
no tenemos que simplificar la respuesta
porque no hay nada que podamos hacer
tanto arriba como abajo para que me
quede una respuesta mucho más
simplificada por lo tanto me quedo con
49 entre 36 y ahora lo voy a escribir
como un número mixto antes me copiarlo
aquí 49 entre 36 y bueno lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta
es que 36 cabe una vez en 49 tenemos un
entero un entero 36 para 49 sobran
36 para 40 son 49 sobran 13 ok 13 y
abajo pues me quedo con el mismo
denominador y eso es muy importante
36 y bueno esto tú lo puedes ver de una
manera muy fácil diciendo 36 cabe una
vez 59 o la otra forma de hacer justo
esto es decir que la fracción la podemos
ver como división 49 entre 36 y
calcularlo justo aquí 49 entre entre 36
y si te das cuenta cabe una vez cabe una
vez uno por 36 es 36 lo voy a restar y
entonces me va a sobrar hagamos la resta
9 menos 6 es 34 menos 3 es uno es decir
que si yo quiero escribir esta fracción
impropia como un número mixto me cabe
una vez tengo un entero que es justo
este de aquí este es el que va a ir
justo
me sobran 13 ese es mi residuo por lo
tanto lo voy a poner ahora como una
fracción propia 13 este 13 va justo acá
y el 36 es mi denominador común a este
no hay que olvidarlo por lo tanto el 36
lo voy a poner justo acá y llegamos a la
misma respuesta un entero 13 entre 36 de
lujo